lundi tu as dit preuil des mon dieu à
une époque où il ça a été vraiment mon
maître à penser
mais ça aussi ça un peu changé d'avis
c'est bien changer d'avis heureusement
que depuis c'est ainsi interview
accordée dans lesquels on diamanka
blement des bêtises c'est bien
conscience d'opinion chalon aux avis
serait très monotone et moi j'ai horreur
des gens qui ne changent pas d'avis ça
fait combien d'années de psychanalyse 8
en 8 ans et si aujourd'hui tu pratiques
en fait eu à pratiquer un moment là la
psychanalyse toi même c'est devenu
analyste wamer en ont un petit peu plus
intéressés pendant des années et je m'y
intéresse toujours enfin déclaré un
livre intéressant j'en prends
connaissance mais disons que tout ça
c'est seiller si tu me voyais arriver
moi un jour en te demandant de
m'analyser quelle serait la première
question tu me poserai la première
question je ne tends poserait pas arrêt
j'attendrai le temps je ne demanderai
pas si je peux te payer par exemple mon
nom au nord une bonne confession 7
dirait alors là j'en raffole
j'y ai passé mon adolescence et moi dans
mon bar comment sais tu me suis un
quand tous mes mots soient vraiment tout
tenté pour dent comme aldo costa
dis moi tu as dit les petits anges
j'ai mis longtemps d'en débarrasser
l'enfer le paradis aujourd'hui tu as
l'air un peu moi anticlérical écoutez
moi je suis un peu comme pascal ce fait
le même pari nous parient sur le fait
que dieu existe
tu remarqueras au passage que c'est bien
un auvergnat de pascal parce que parier
sur dieu yakan auvergnats qui brûle toi
tu l'appelles le hasard dieu tu trouves
un autre nom toi c'est les bisontins qui
m'appellent le hasard mais toile alors
disons qu'à mais alors ça tombe très
bien parce que j'ai une grande
admiration pour la religion byzance
c'est vrai que la bible est un livre de
chevet c'est exact tu lis souvent tous
les soirs et quelquefois le matin et en
plus c'est pas un bouquin triste très
joyeux et assez paillard ça dépend des
châteaux est ce que finalement ça peut
être illusoire de croire que tu pouvait
échapper au p'tit jacques du collège
je suis toujours resté le p'tit jacques
du collège et les mêmes terreur je
déteste autant les adultes
je suis resté le garçon que j'étais au
pensionnat il faut pas le dire ça me
fera du tort
un dernier mot à rennes samedi dernier
double